[MUSIC PLAYING]
SUZANNE FREY: I am so excited
to welcome you here today
to connect, to celebrate,
and even to do some creating.
AVNI SHAH: Engaging with
other professional women,
getting together and
building a community where
we support and celebrate
each other-- this
is important to me.
ALAINA PERCIVAL: Making
sure that the world knows
that there are actually a
ton of smart, ambitious,
and qualified women
in the tech industry.
NATALIE VILLALOBOS:
Women in general
don't sell themselves enough.
Right?
Like, you have so
many strengths.
You do such incredible work.
TELLE WHITNEY: Yes, you
need to have the best
career you can possibly
have, but what can
you do to help others?
PAVNI DIWANJI: It doesn't
take very long or very much
effort to help
another woman in need.
It doesn't take very
much to help someone
with their coding problem.
KATE STIRR: What I
would really like
to solve for is creating a
global culture that supports
building confidence
in young women
so that they can
choose whether they
want to be artists, or
scientists, or some combination
thereof.
TELLE WHITNEY: We want
you to be at the table,
creating the technology that
will change all of our lives.
And each one of you
can help make that so.
[MUSIC PLAYING]